last week tonight asks how is this still
a thing this week
Hollywood whitewashing how is this still
a thing
in just one week we'll celebrate the
Academy Awards they promised to be
controversial as for the second year
running the nominees are whiter than a
Yeti in a snowstorm fighting Tilda
Swinton and yet some are arguing it's
not entirely the Academy's fault some
observers say Hollywood just doesn't
provide enough good roles for black
actors one of the reasons for this might
be that even when there are roles for
non-white actors they sometimes still
get played by white people in Prince of
Persia based on a video game set in
ancient Iran Jake Gyllenhaal plays the
title character that's right Jake
Gyllenhaal a white American with a
Swedish last name was cast to play the
Prince of Persia from you know Persia
and was far from alone just last year
Emma Stone played the half-asian Allison
Eng in Aloha Oh apparently Aloha means
hello goodbye and you've got to be
kidding me
and the hollywood needed actors to play
egyptians in Exodus gods and kings it
knew just what to do Moses promises
you'll grow up together close as
brothers that was a guy from Australia
and a guy from Britain
pretending to be two guys from Egypt a
country in Africa and if you like that
don't miss gods of Egypt opening Friday
starring a Scottish guy I shall be your
one true God Wow that's the whitest
Egyptian since these four
all of this is nothing new white actors
have taken roles designed for every
ethnicity throughout Hollywood history
from John Wayne as Genghis Khan in the
Conqueror your treacherous head is not
safe on your shoulders to the non Puerto
Rican Natalie Wood as Maria in West Side
Story when that's not you to the
multiple instances of white actors
playing Asian characters from Marlon
Brando II by name interpreter by
position to of course this it's a
performance the New York Times in 1961
actually praised as broadly exotic
seriously yes there's no shortage of
roles for white actors playing non-white
characters the historical figure you're
playing wasn't white not a problem
the contemporary figure you're playing
wasn't white not a problem the cartoon
the movie was based on was entirely
about non-white people not a problem
your characters are named Esteban and
Clara true Ava in the Isabella and a
novel the movie is based on right this
way Jeremy Irons and Meryl Streep and
even a non-white person does for a major
role when they make the porn parody
guess what happens don't worry I got
this
and when filmmakers get called out on
whitewashing the justification is less
to do with black and white and more to
do with green director Ridley Scott told
Variety magazine he can't mount a 140
million dollar film and say that my lead
actor is Mohammad so-and-so from
such-and-such yeah you needed the
white-hot star power of whoever the
this guy canal do all of us would be
less egregious that anytime an actor of
color took on a traditionally white role
half the country didn't go eight
the appearance of a black stormtrooper
in the first trailer for star wars the
force awakens is causing a lot of
chatter on social media even some racist
comments several people were apparently
upset that the actors playing the
character is african-american he'd be
the first black bond the author of those
Bond novels saying Elba is to quote
Street yes if you're black even if
you're an actor who sometimes dresses
like French Waldo people will still say
you're too straight and this isn't even
getting into how movies about minorities
will still put white people in the
foreground how are we supposed to
believe Tom Cruise at the Last Samurai
this guy is the Last Samurai this guy
this guy is the Last Samurai you so
you know people say the Oscars are so
white because the rules aren't fair just
remember the Academy gave Oscars for
characters named Olin Billy Kwan and
Louis Molina two actors named Louise
Linda and William all of which is enough
to make you ask Hollywood whitewashing
how is this still a thing